- We had Jenna on this show.
I love your daughter, by
the way, she's so fun.
I kind of feel like we were separated
at birth every time we hang out.
But she mentioned that the
White House was haunted.
Did you ever experience that?
- No, we'd never.
I think Barbara and Jenna
were the ones that felt
like there was that it was haunted
and pretended like they heard voices
and it's probably just
the secret service talking
down the hall in another
room that they heard.
But we didn't think it was haunted.
We love living there,
it's a magnificent house.
And it has a magnificent art collection
which was also fun to
have the chance to live
with those beautiful paintings.
- It's definitely a beautiful house.
I will say that I've
been there a few times
and living there would
have been a little daunting
for a kid, I think.
(laughing)
I think, I would have been terrified.
Okay, so I'm not sure if you know this,
but today is National No Dirty Dishes Day.
So who washes more dishes in your house?
I think I know this answer.
You or President--
- Well you know that answer.
- I know that answer.
(laughing)
- Of course, I do.
Of course I do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.